[MUSIC PLAYING]
SEAN MCQUILLAN: Welcome
to Lightning Talks.
I'm super excited to be here
today and talk to you about how
to welcome your users
to your Android app
when they get a new phone.
So why is this important?
So if you think about
the Android ecosystem,
it runs on phones, right?
And we all get a new phone
every two, maybe three, years.
And when we do this,
we reinstall all
of the apps we've installed.
And we do this, and all
of our users of our apps
do this as well.
You do a little bit of
math, you figure out,
if you buy a new
phone every two years,
that means half of
your users are going
to get a new phone this year.
If you don't do anything at
all with your application,
you're going to give them a cold
welcome when they come back.
And you're going to show
them an email and a password
form that's going to
be like they've never
used your app before.
You're completely disrupting
their flow of using your app.
What you want to do instead
is offer them a warm welcome.
You want to welcome them
back to your application
and create this continuous
user experience that
jumps from their old
device to their new device,
so you don't have
any friction, you
don't have any
retention problems,
for these users that are
switching devices and using
your application.
There's a couple of products
you can use from Google
that help you do this.
So one of them is
Google Sign-In.
I think everyone knows what
Google Sign-In is, right?
It's a button you
press, and you log in.
So it's a button you
It's amazing for
this flow exactly
because it's very simple
to do that log-in.
So it's good for your
activation originally
because it's easy to
log into your app.
But when they get
a new phone, it's
also good for reactivating
these users, because all they do
is have to click a button.
And on an Android, you
can even configure it
so they don't even have to click
the button on the new device.
They'll automatically log in.
Google Sign-In works on iOS,
Android, as well as the web.
So you can use it
everywhere, and it's
a great way to add federated
log-in to your application.
Another feature you
can use on Android
is Smart Lock for Passwords.
So Smart Lock is-- well,
it's a password manager.
It's named quite well.
So it stores usernames
and passwords, or even
federated credentials,
up in the cloud
when the user confirms that they
would like to save the password
after they log in.
So they're going to do
this on their old phone.
They're going to
save their password.
And then when they get
onto their new device,
when they first come
into your application,
you're going to give
them this warm welcome.
You're going to say,
I know who you are.
Do you want to log in with
that account you've already
saved for this application?
And it's just going to create
that seamless experience
and log that user
into your application.
So one of our partners,
Netflix, who I believe
is here today, actually--
so Netflix used this,
and they found that they had
20% fewer support requests.
And so if you think about
that, maybe every time
a user contacts you to get
a username and password fix,
there's probably five users
that didn't, and they're just
not going to come back to
your application for months
or even years at a time.
They might just become
a retention problem.
They may never come back.
So this is a fantastic way to
improve your business metrics.
And then Autofill
is a new feature
relaunched in
Android O. It works
kind of like Smart
Lock when it comes
to usernames and passwords.
So it's an autofill system.
Right?
So it autofills text views
exactly the way you think.
And one of the most common
text views to get autofilled
is usernames and passwords.
So the way this
works is, after they
log into your application
on their old device,
they'll choose to save it
to the Autofill service,
and that's going to go up to the
same data store as Smart Lock.
It's a secure data
store for passwords.
And then when they come
back on their new device,
it's just going to go
ahead and autofill.
So there's a couple
things you can
do to get your application
ready for Autofill.
One of the biggest
ones is set up
a digital asset link that links
your web and your Android app.
So this is great because
Autofill has pluggable password
managers, but all the password
managers support this.
And when they do
that, what happens
is the user can
log in on the web.
And if they're using the
same password manager
on their Android
device, they're going
to go ahead and get those
credentials transferred.
So they log in on the web,
install your Android app,
and the password's
already saved.
They get the seamless
upgrade experience
to your Android application.
Another thing you have to
do for Autofill-- well,
you don't have to
do it, but if you
want the best
experience for users--
you should set up autofillHints.
So you should tell the Autofill
service what the username, what
the password field is.
That way, the Autofill
service doesn't
have to guess based on your
IDs and maybe get it wrong,
which is probably
the worst experience
you can give your users.
And then the last thing
we're going to talk about
is Auto Backup.
I'm going to hand
it over to Jeremy.
JEREMY ORLOW: Yep.
So Auto Backup is a great way
to also provide continuity
to your users.
So even if your app
syncs to the cloud,
there's still usually
device-specific settings
that you can backup.
And there's also--
no user who's been
using your app for a year wants
to see a tutorial first thing
when they launch your app
when they're on a new phone.
So Auto Backup works by--
when the phone's idle,
we backup to the cloud.
Your data is stored securely.
You can have up to 25 megs.
But if you go over
that, backups will fail.
On the new phone, when
the user installs the app,
it will restore the
data before the app runs
for the first time,
and the user picks up
where they left off without
any friction or churn.
You can also include and
exclude specific files.
So, for example, you can exclude
OAuth tokens or other things
that shouldn't be backed up.
And with all these tools, it's
possible to provide continuity
to your users and
keep them engaged
when they switch phones.
We'll be back in the back.
[MUSIC PLAYING]